hello my name is Ashley today I'm going
to show you how to make homemade natural
pesticide
so what for the trees that when you have
bugs and things like that emphas to how
to get rid of it without putting
chemicals so what it is is in a cup you
put some water and you have any kind of
jalapeno pepper that's really hot you
take the stems out
you just drop it in
as many as you want four or five because
the cup is you know not too big so you
put about six seven five whatever two or
three doesn't matter just close the if
you have any kind of blender it doesn't
matter this kind of blender doesn't
matter any blender it will work you just
close it
make sure I was gonna say that put the
gloves in your hands still it's not hot
yet but after you do the work you make
sure for I'm gonna make a noise for a
second I'm gonna blend it
you take it out and see if
there is any big pieces which is all you
see it it's crumbled use a few more
minutes
it takes about two to three minutes a
second that's all you need now I have to
wear my gloves you know from the
beginning you can wear it it's almost
always it's safer and sometimes when you
do this the fume it can burn your nose
like the so what you do is you can put
sometimes your mask on so what you do is
you take a cheese cloth or any kind of
material that little bags which I use
this a lot for a lot of things to use
for dish for the kitchen you put in a
strainer and under there is a plastic
container Tupperware it doesn't matter
whatever it is make it simple easy
you go through to the
to the cloth the cheesecloth and you let
it
not because we have to put in a spray
bottle we don't want any particle pieces
because it will plug the the hose the
pipe
and it's good to wear a mask like I said
it's kind of hot perfumes
but anyway I have to show you this way
and then what you do is
I have a spray that I bought it here
this is for my spray that I paid to
spray my
trees
I have to open it
you put some water in it it's about like
a gallon gallon and a half again it
doesn't matter warmer hotter it is the
spice spicy it is it's better in a
gallon of
you pour it in
and you close it
make sure that you close it very tight
because whenever you spray it now
whenever you spray make sure this time
really
well this is the best way to do it
and when you have to spray it you have
to wear a mask and a goggle
otherwise it will from the air from the
wind it's gonna blow your side and it
might burn your eyes or your breathing
all right thank you very much this is
very simple Israel be inspired and try
it thank you very much for watching I'll
see you next time bye bye